What is your craziest
interaction with a fan?
Um, I got my dick sucked
on stage.
[ cheering ]
I'm sorry.
What?
[ all laughing ]
Yeah, it was kind of fun.
Were you facing the stage
or facing away and kind of
moving to the music?
I was still performing.
You were still rapping
while you were getting
your dick sucked?
Yeah.
Give me a moment,
Danny.
Give me a moment.
[ exhales ]
Good God.
What has happened?
Have I got as a homie
the coolest person
in the world?
[ chuckles ]
Danny, now, listen.
What is your relationship
with marijuana?
Oh, we go way back.
Yeah, you do.
Yeah, I guess it started back--
I was about 13, maybe.
You know, the first time
I tasted it, I was like,
"Oh, my God.
Where have you been
all my life?"
"Where have you been
for 13 years?"
Yeah, exactly.
So, Danny,
what's the weirdest thing
you've ever smoked weed
out of?
I think I was in jail,
with an apple.
Yeah, how did you get
marijuana into a jail?
I don't know.
I'm pretty sure it came through
in somebody's booty, though.
[ all groaning ]
Hey, look, when you're in jail,
you gotta smoke that booty weed.
Yeah.
Somebody goes
through the trouble
of sticking weed
up their booty for you,
you gotta smoke it.
Rude not to.